cedric the entertainer has been making
audiences laugh for more than three
decades he's appeared in dozens of hit
films and TV shows like The Steve Harvey
Show the soul man and the last og he
currently stars as Calvin Butler on the
CBS series the neighborhood it explores
what happens when a white family from
the Midwest moves next door to a black
family in Los Angeles in this clip
neighbor Dave volunteers to help Calvin
with his annual cookout so what'd you
say girl you really bring a little
flavor to the neighborhood I was just
going for a jog but sure I was talking
to my smoker day getting ready for the
yard too cute is weekend oh yeah that's
right your last yard akyuu was the day
we moved in can you believe that we've
been neighbors for a year I know it
feels like so much longer right so what
can I do to help
you can start by wearing longer shorts
Cedric the Entertainer welcome thanks
for being here got a hit yeah what do
you think happened why is it resonating
you know I think you know we're in a
time where you know we seem to be asked
to be separate more separate and so this
show is like just talking about
something that's kind of real I mean the
gentrification
I deal communities being meshed together
it's really going around in a lot of
cities and so I think that this show
just kind of made sense and that we we
really wanted to have fun about how we
can get to know each other once we live
next to each other as opposed to just
having these preconceived notions about
people people here you're in it they
hear it's a comedy they might think it's
just laugh out loud comedy the whole
time but you mentioned the there are
serious issues involved there's
gentrification there's discrimination
there's there's Parenthood why was it
important to put those issues on the
table as well because I think those are
the all the same really those items make
us common you know if you're your father
or mother brother you know we end up as
people having the same issues except
that culturally we kind of maybe deal
with them you know in a different way
but when you when you get to know
another culture or another person you
realize it's the same stories and so we
kind of felt like you know it was
important to have marriage and kids and
different age differences and so those
are the kind of things so the couple of
lot younger than we are and so we but
we're because we're to married men we
kind of identify with each other so it's
that kind of thing your character is
described as a bit cranky but keep it
real by keeping these characters
authentic to what would really happen
out in the real world yeah that was one
of the big things about even doing this
show on it you know the our creator Jim
Reynolds a great guy if this was his
life experience and so when he was
writing the story he was writing it from
the white guy that moved in he was and
he thought he was being authentic to the
black guy I was like so when we became
partners on it it was more about like
all right cool let's let's figure out
what we both want to say in this
situation and then we'll have a show you
actually shoot this in front of a live
studio audience yeah
people don't realize that point out yeah
it's good that's interesting isn't I
mean it's a bullet man you know I mean
because there's a stand-up you know I'm
used to that live audience that word
that instant reaction it's almost a
throwback to old school televisions yeah
when the live audience happens but that
that particular format works for me
because you know you get the energy
right there yeah and it's like doing a
play except when you get to mess up and
start over but it still is that that
that energy of people like filling it
right at the moment that really happen
if it doesn't play in the room when
you're taping you'll rewrite it and do
it again yes yes yes we get the that's
that's the blessing about doing a
written TV show we get to stop in like
all right cool that joke didn't fly you
know you rethinking it was gonna kill
like all week and they go like it went
over people's heads so they we had to
come back you'll see the huddle guys
huddle up and if I start writing jokes
yes I guess you get immediate feedback
you started in stand-up comedy but but
really you you kind of started as a
claims adjuster yeah but I was like a
claims adjuster so you know if um it was
Auto claims so and I wouldn't that
wasn't that good I think it'd steal some
people in a rental car from back when I
did maybe giving you a call back most
folks remember you from The Steve Harvey
Show and I got to give a shout out to
Wendy Raquel Robinson my college
roommate who started with you on that
show but so much of your your fame and I
would presume how you were trained in
television started then and there
exactly that was my first situational
comedy you know like I came from
stand-up Steve and I were good friends
as their stand-ups and so they had the
opportunity to go on the show with him
at that time was there's a great
learning ground and you know we had a
great time we had you know what's the
best advice he gave you Steve the best
advice Steve ever gave me was really
just be my authentic self I I came up to
New York one time to perform for a bunch
of executives and I changed like my
whole routine trying to be corporate and
I bombed in me and it see one of them
cursed everybody
oh you can do that he was like yeah be
yourself soin hats - yeah who said you
talk to bladder friends he needs an
entertainer thanks season two the
neighborhood premieres Monday at 8:00
7:00 central right here on CBS